[Music]
so how do you maximize your views on
YouTube in this training I'm going to be
going through some simple YouTube
strategies that you can try for reaching
your first 1000 subscribers and Beyond
growing your channel and today I'm
joined by a friend a YouTube expert Dan
from vid IQ and we're gonna be breaking
down some channels now we're not doing
um open Channel reviews but we've got
some strategic channels that you're
going to be able to learn from
um and how you can apply that to your
videos your shorts maybe your branding
so that ultimately you can stand out and
grow in a 2023 YouTube world and we're
also going to be doing a title training
specifically a little bit on how to
write more powerful titles so you can
get more clicks so that ultimately you
can get more views but I want to welcome
Dan to the stream today Dan how's it
going it's going fantastic thanks for
having me how's everybody
yes uh we're fired up shout us out where
you're watching from and I'm excited to
dive into the first channel today and
we're gonna be breaking down and of
course extrapolating tips that we can
learn and apply to our channels and this
is geology dude and so let's get a
vision here hello Rock people I'm Dave
geology dude a college professor and
geologist and his channel is all about
rock identification
um let's see we've got uh some videos
over here on the tab Martha Lake erratic
big rock we've got a historic gold blue
it mining District Washington Rock here
um I'll be coming to you Dan first but
just getting an overview we've got some
shorts going over here
and uh geology Jude's over at Tick Tock
551 subscribers let's do a little Health
audit here we got 13 000 views in the
last 28 days 77 new subscribers with 19
uploads and so I think two weeks one
month he's definitely tapped into shorts
the maybe two videos of Longs in the
last month but over here on shorts would
be where a lot of those uploads are
coming from and maybe the boosted views
are from a couple 500s here looks like a
700 view here 4
400 View
smoky quartz short who would have
thought man this is exciting YouTube has
so many different niches and different
types of opportunities so Dan what are
some of your initial thoughts on how
this channel could grow a little bit
faster
when I I'm trying to get a sense of what
the channel is doing in the videos
because when I see this I think okay so
this is a great opportunity to give us
some facts about the different uh you
know rocks and minerals that you're
you're looking at oh I can't hear the
audio what were they saying in this oh
you turned you muted it
all right hello Rock people geology dude
this this is the big rock in Martha Lake
introduction and the definition of an
erratic he's got uh some good chapters
on here examples of sediment
characteristics of right so it's kind of
a it feels like an education Channel
maybe like if you were to go to a
history class at geology class I should
say and learn about rocks and learn
about the facts of the rocks
so I wonder if one thing that could help
um is really focusing because I'm trying
to think like okay how would I get this
content to relate to me
as someone who doesn't really yeah I
don't have an inherent interest in this
but there's probably a lot of really
cool facts that I would appreciate I'd
find really neat but I would I would
need something to tie it to me so I
think
um it's it's a good strategy already
like Martha Lake you know as like okay
this is the location I'm in and this is
the kind of stuff you can find but I
kind of wonder if the titles could be
like even more impactful
um you know like uh historic oh sorry I
was reading the title
um the the titles I think need to be a
little more impactful here to kind of
bring me in because right now the titles
we were seeing feel very straightforward
that very matter of fact
so historic gold ingot id'd
what have what's the value of the gold
for example like try to find different
ways to bring this back around so the
Layman can appreciate it like you know I
you know this gold was found here and
guess what if you were to sell this
right now it would be worth like a
million dollars you know I think just
those types of facts tying it into like
stuff everyday people would be really
excited to learn about would help a lot
yeah and I'm I'm right with you like
where success leaves Clues and so where
how have maybe different channels become
more edutainment uh maybe evolved uh
creating interest in this I also think
it's fascinating
um I wonder what about these shorts here
potentially you know this this quartz
one what was interesting about this you
just have music playing
this is the dimensions of it
and he's definitely doing some 3D
imaging 3D modeling of these
and his original music probably
royalty-free music of some kind kind of
some folk music playing
I I think this would be great with a
voiceover
like did you know you could find this in
this region and uh it you know it takes
these types of tools to dig it up
because it's the hardest rock in the
world like just start throwing really
random facts about this mineral at
people you know I I think with shorts
that's going to really get the shorts
viewer to stop scrolling for a second
even if they're not interested in this
topic because you're just throwing kind
of cool facts at them I think I think
your idea of kind of a Ripley's Believe
It or Not
an opening of a voiceover on shorts of
did you know that these rocks were from
the dinosaur time and you show Dinosaurs
in there maybe these you know that and
and you even what's interesting is you
probably could tie up into there's a lot
of rock culture rocks have healing
properties you know I I maybe this is
we're talking to a geologist here so I
could be very wrong of course but you
have a lot like the lava rock is like
good for you know don't they have a
benefit you know somebody could shout us
out in the comments uh you know you get
those love I mean my wife has like one
and like what is it like clear the room
of Wi-Fi or something you know
um and so uh yeah what are maybe
different benefits and that's a great
idea and so uh those are definitely some
good tips regarding um the channel here
and uh really cool I think this is such
a strong Niche it definitely ties into I
think if you also think about and you're
probably getting some search regarding
this
um you think about students and I'm sure
sure students would use a challenge a
channel like this for a utility
geology and and geology is obviously
huge so this channel is for educational
purpose you must hire a professional
geologist to determine applicable
information related to properly property
and so uh great Channel though and
awesome consistency and way to use
shorts have you started using shorts
think media podcasts let us know in the
comment section below we're also going
to be taking some questions today and
the way we do it is you put four
questions before and after your
um questioned for question marks so that
we really can see that sending out is a
question but let's dive into the second
channel here we've got um
Circle H scuba education equipment
experiences environment
we have 300 subscribers
over here on our stats we've been having
a blow up
449 percent growing this is vid IQ
showing us our stats 147 subscribers 190
new subscribers 46 uploads and it's my
hunch Dan that that is because of shorts
uh it would seem that let's see a day
ago eight days ago two weeks ago pretty
consistent with the Longs but actually
total longs started uploading two months
ago and that might this might be an
absolutely brand new channel so this
channel joined October 2022 so we're
just getting started love the momentum
we're seeing here and so then definitely
um shorts being the key to get to that
46 uploads and I think you know again
what are the takeaways for you watching
this today for your channel don't ignore
shorts
um for the chance to trigger Channel
growth and be more consistent get more
uploads but Dan what are some of your
thoughts
this is really really cool stuff like
this is the kind of thing I like to see
with channels you have access to
something that not a lot of people have
access to and so you get to show
perspectives and show things that just
people don't get to see a lot which
creates a very high barrier to entry
it's hard to replicate this content it's
hard to get it anywhere else and so
you're playing to your strengths in a
big way as you're looking through this
video like the the shots are incredible
they're using a lot of b-roll uh you can
tell this is just uh you know from Soup
To Nuts just a really really cool
channel that has like a ton of potential
yeah very cool uh very crispy footage
cool branding
way to do uh your um
logo Sting If you're gonna have kind of
an intro or a logo about a second and a
half is the recommended length and so
that's really great
way to get straight into the content
here
and some good opportunity for affiliate
marketing tapping into anybody who does
want to do some underwater video and
photos off the top of my head one video
idea that comes to mind is always
thinking about a little bit of broad
appeal scuba divers are always going to
be a little bit
um more Niche because you've already
maybe considered yourself that or you're
aspiring to be that what I actually
rather than thinking about scuba divers
I wonder if you tapped into travel
snorkelers and because a lot of people
it'd be very common would be like I'm
about to go on vacation yeah in fact
that's that's when everybody buys a
GoPro yeah like let me know there's got
to be at least one person here live or
on the replay
you uh we're gonna go on vacation and
you bought a GoPro because of it and
then you also maybe never used it but
like that is the most common thing
you're like dude I am I need a drone I
need a GoPro because I'm finally going
on vacation then you go you use it like
one time you're afraid you're gonna
crash your drone you find out it's a
legal there you're Nolan mole and you
take a think media GoPro on your
vacation to Mexico and lose it true
story uh and so we never saw that
footage it probably would have been
great and so uh it's too funny and um
and hey check this out Circle H scuba
has done 99 in Amazon Affiliates wow
remember already brand new channel
started in October 2022 it's 2023 now
since December so what would that be
December January February in three
months brand new channel 300 subscribers
100 bucks an Amazon Affiliates friend
the Creator economy is alive and well
but of course you got to be making the
right videos and and Circle H scuba uh
scuba is a video ranking Academy student
so great job with that we of course go a
lot deeper in that kind of stuff inside
of the academy but uh really cool and uh
this is not a pre-recorded video Nathan
we are here live doing some reviews of
our VRA students but uh anyways I I need
to actually look at the comments and see
if anyone actually lost their GoPro but
let's get back to the channel
any other thoughts Dan how do you think
how do you feel about these thumbnails I
think the thumbnails are good start
there's not like a ton of elements in a
lot of these but they could be I think a
little bit better uh one thing I don't
think you need is your logo in the
thumbnail it's a nice logo but it's
going to be underneath your video on a
lot of home pages and search pages and
things like that so it's just another
thing in your thumbnail kind of
cluttering it up uh I I think one of the
thumbnails that's really standing out to
me is this one in the middle the best
settings for the you know the GoPro
there uh and it's it's underwater so
that that I like it's just nice and
simple nice and clean uh but yeah some
of these are just a little more busy
than others I try to like tone that down
a little bit
yeah and I think uh you do have a
massive opportunity with YouTube shorts
um I also would think one thought here
and we just did a YouTube shorts master
class and uh definitely check that out
if you didn't catch it I believe you did
um you know being on camera and teaching
is great uh but there's just so much
power in a vertical video format you
know one of the videos we did here
recently at think media was on the best
books for YouTube and so keeping its you
know voice over and keeping the interest
of the on-screen content at a
10 10 and Visually entertaining I think
it's just something that especially in
shorts and so I had a video where I
talked about the best books that every
YouTube Creator should read and it was
me like holding them up and then there's
this video where it's just
you know it started off with the mystery
of the books and then it's just the
b-roll of the books and they're the
heroes it's the visual like you're able
to look at the cover read the cover and
this one's doing a lot better and so
um all that to say is that uh kind of
like the rock Channel voice over some
good music maybe some text reinforcing
maybe some quick edits to hold that
viewer retention and I think you also
have a a series you could do on shorts
that's kind of a believe it or not like
just that wow and Sensational like did
you know that octopus you know and that
you could get good like big reach from
some of those shorts that could bring
exposure to the channel and then there's
always got to be a little bit of caution
with that meaning you you start maybe if
you want to be an education channel for
scuba divers and tapping into some
people traveling and wanting to snorkel
and do that if you attract a lot of
people I mean Dan I'm curious about that
the specific question for you as an
expert is with the opportunity in shorts
to be more broad to kind of go talk
about almost anything I looked at Alex
tremozzi recently who's a business coach
uh basically and his most viewed short
is him talking about how he used to to
spend uh to buy 500 transactions at
Chipotle in a year and so so we talk
about niching down but he goes when I
was single uh I ate at Chipotle over 500
times in one year and that's his by far
most viewed short what's your thought on
on us saying Niche down be focused but
especially in vertical video the fact
that like it seems you start going more
broad appeal lifestyle something funny
that you can get a lot of reach but is
it the right reach
yeah I think there's a it's like there's
a fine line there because now would you
say that channel should focus on
Chipotle content I don't think so it
feels very personality driven and if
that's what you want to be and a lot of
creators do want this they want to be
personality driven channels then sharing
more of yourself shorts is probably a
really great place to do that one
conundrum we see from you know just a
question we're constantly getting how do
I get the people to come from my shorts
to my Longs and if they're just two
totally different worlds that's really
hard to do so it's I think it's about
striking a balance between things you
would do in your long-form videos and
just trying to build a bridge between
that and doing something somewhat
similar but maybe a little more off the
wall on your shorts I think you get away
with that in shorts one opportunity
right now is music as well music
channels struggle to like Breakthrough
if they're writing original songs no
one's searching for those but shorts
It's just gonna put it in front of
somebody and the song is gonna start
playing and people get to decide in an
instant oh oh this sounds pretty good I
kind of like this you know so the
opportunity is there for so many people
I still would encourage people to do
something that it like arguably is
somewhat similar or at least true to
your personality throughout your entire
channel so it all makes sense
great great advice there Dan we are
going through some tips that are going
to help you grow your channel if you
have a question put four question marks
before and after the question we're
gonna be looking at a few channels from
our um video record Academy Community
we're not taking any new channel reviews
today but we have a couple more channels
to get through and so hit like if you've
been already getting value and in just a
second we're going to be looking at the
stay at home bearded Chef uh but today's
video is brought to you by vid IQ and if
you haven't already grabbed a 30-day
trial on vidiq's paid plan you could get
it for just a dollar at vidiq.com
forward slash think a little bit later
Dan's going to be taking us through how
we can write better titles one of the
biggest keys to
um getting more clicks and really
actually clarifying your video ideas
themselves uh which will lead to better
topics better titles overall uh but vid
iq's got some really cool tools so check
out the link the description for that
and we'll be circling back on that in a
little bit but Dan let's check out the
next channel here which is the stay at
home bearded chef and so joined back in
2021 but has only been uploading Longs
for a month ago and then two weeks ago
you have two videos we do have some
shorts coming out here
and our stats uh I have yet to populate
because we're still in the very early
days of the channel but almost 4 000
views and so we're super early stage I
think this is a big opportunity for if
someone's just starting if they haven't
started yet
um and how they could maybe build some
momentum what are your thoughts for
stay-at-home bearded chef yeah welcome
to YouTube first of all I think uh this
is a fun idea I already like the
personality just the name kind of like
already kind of gives you an idea and I
love that I I think for this channel uh
one thing I was noticing the titles
thumbnails is going to be topics you
know when you when you were deciding
what kind of content to make it really
is important to think about the audience
you're making it for so for example Utah
residents stay at home Cooks side hustle
2023 so it kind of feels like there's a
lot going on in that title right like
Utah residents stay at home Cooks so are
we targeting specifically People from
Utah who cook and want to do it as a
side hustle like because it just feels
like that's like kind of Niche a lot
based on the way I'm perceiving the
title it's probably not like that but be
thinking about it from a more broad
perspective like if you are a cook what
kind of side hustles are there for you
you know and you would probably have the
answer to that as the Creator behind
this channel so now you're thinking
about different titles that can more
cater to that broader audience because
why do I have to live in Utah for it I
could probably do this in all kinds of
locales so or maybe it's a specific
reason maybe Utah has some kind of scene
that I don't understand but I still
don't think that would be like the title
I think it'd be just kind of like a you
know hey like I found this thing and it
happens to be in my local area maybe
your area has something similar to it so
I I would try to like open that up to a
broader audience
let's jump in for a little video review
here
[Music]
we go hey what is up guys this is Chris
with the stay at home bearded Chef uh
bringing you today some awesome awesome
news some of you may know about it but
from 2021 a lot of people I believe
don't know about it especially
stay-at-home chefs like you and me or
wanting to be one
um anyway it's called the micro
Enterprise home kitchen Act
all right so a couple thoughts here on
the opening of the video that a lot of
us can learn from and forgive me for
hitting you with the 1010 volume
especially blown out Dan's headphones
and sorry for anybody else listening on
headphones
so we want to really rework the
beginning of this video an opportunity
that we can all learn from is first we
want to get a strong topic that's
value-based to the user then really
figure out what that what that is so
you're saying there's a new act in Utah
even this topic itself may not be at the
top of the list of a video that's going
to truly get reached or help you reach
the goal but if we were to rework this a
couple I would argue Mistakes One
with this branding we we took five
seconds
before any value or before being hooked
in any way
um by what the topic was why I should
watch why I should be interested and so
typically you should start right up
front on camera and say like are you
looking to and if this is an act that
helps you want to double your income as
a home Chef as a as or you want to
figure out how to make more money you
want to start a a stay-at-home cook side
hustle job in this video I'm going to be
sharing a brand new act that's going to
change you know and so starting on
camera starting with questions that are
up a question that creates curiosity or
a tease of what's coming or a reason to
watch till the end then the second thing
is even after that first five seconds
you you go straight again to it's it's
about you it's like it's like what your
channel is about let's watch hey what is
up guys this is Chris with the stay at
home bearded Chef uh bringing you today
some awesome awesome news some of you
may know about it but from 2021 a lot of
people I believe don't know about it so
again I would encourage you Chris that
actually with love nobody cares about
you yet and that's the advice we need
you to hear like hey we love you like
and we and eventually they might but
what they care about is the problem they
want to solve they care about so if
you're like hey it's Chris like a lot of
I think it's our opinion that in 2023
you can almost trim this out completely
or you put it a lot further in the video
so get straight to the point like get
right into it in regards to you could
say you open with uh hey do you want to
learn how to make more money
cooking as a side hustle in this video
I'm going to be talking about a brand
new act in Utah if you live there which
again that's a little niche if we could
go a little bit broader maybe uh but I'm
gonna actually be breaking down like the
three ways to apply for this and then
how uh this past month I was actually
able to like double my bookings from
using a cool new piece of software let's
get into tip number one boom and you
could add value right up front and then
maybe even between tip one and tip two
if at all you you could actually
introduce yourself later or never like
that's actually my 2023 opinion that if
someone's interested in you they will
follow they'll find out you can put on
screen your name and your social media
logos but just get straight to the value
and the clip meaning the paid it the the
pace meeting the the gate weird words
meaning the the chalk meaning the pace
of of the editing is just like the title
hook me the thumbnail hook me
now I'm watching the beginning and I
want to keep watching now you're already
delivering value and I can't click away
and anytime we just kind of go into like
marketing or promotion mode it's just
sort of a moment to where yes people
could care and it's not the end of the
world but there's just like there's no
reason necessarily to put that in just
keep the conversation going and if you
do think about how you could do it
shortly it'd be like at the beginning of
this video I was like Hey we're gonna do
some YouTube training are you going to
learn some tips we're gonna do a title
training later and so let's dive into
the first channel welcome Dan not a lot
and this is my style I know some people
are a little bit more relational or
whatnot but not a lot of conversation or
anything just trying to get right to the
value and then maybe later you get into
things and if I introduce myself I might
say but if you're new to the channel my
name is Sean Cannell rhymes with YouTube
channel I help people grow their
influence on YouTube but let's get right
into it and so just thinking about how
to get right into it could really help I
believe
um this video and then and and then the
punch line is about the time you
introduce the concept we're like 30 or
40 seconds in we're trying to get to
that value in like second one through
four not second forty and then thinking
about how you are articulating and
pitching whatever this is in a very
simple way but again respect as Dan said
welcome to YouTube we're so early and so
I hope that this actually kind of
feedback is really helpful for just
tweaking your next few uploads uh Dan
any other things you want to hit here as
we're looking at the channel
uh just just keep trying to find
incremental ways to improve as you go
one thing I'm noticing is just with the
quality of the content itself like if
your camera could be eye level I think
that would help a lot just kind of uh
it's the perspective right now is kind
of strange we're always just kind of
like like a toy on your shelf you know
where you're always just kind of going
to look down at us so see about getting
your your camera a little more eye level
just these are little nitpicks I'm
coming up with right now just to help
you when you're thinking about ways to
improve your quality like just to kind
of give you some stepping stones this is
not all stuff you need to worry about
overnight if you have to get gear you
got to get lights you gotta do all this
stuff
um but yeah I'd be thinking about that
just just off the top of my head but for
someone who's made two long form videos
and just a handful of shorts I'm already
really impressed with your on-camera
presence like overall your energy uh it
just you feel very warm and inviting and
I want to know more uh just what we're
seeing here it looks like you know
you're you're holding up a giant pepper
so like I'm already getting in the mood
for like okay what are you gonna make
with this you know so there's already a
lot of things going on that are right so
I think this is a really strong start
for for someone new to YouTube and
that's a great point you bring up Dan my
guess here is this is perhaps a webcam
so the laptop is on the the table so the
hack could be if that's all you have is
get some boxes and even get the webcam
at a vantage point more eye level as you
mentioned and thinking about that shot
composition it also seems like maybe
from the other that it's a SmartPhone of
some kind even that was kind of
interesting you you could it looks like
you press record and then you step back
even just using your Droid or Android or
or iPhone you can hit record walk over
and then just slide the front of the
video to have the start point and also
editing in YouTube shorts you could do
the same but if it is a smartphone your
biggest bang for your buck would be to
uh either get your laptop a little bit
higher stack it up on some boxes you
could use the same free trick for doing
that with your uh with your smartphone
but I would everybody on here should
invest if you're doing mobile Creation
in some kind of a a tripod for your
phone
and uh probably one of the best ways to
do it I might avoid
um these ones that get a little top
heavy they have the little legs at the
bottom and what you'd probably want is
you want a tripod with a smartphone
Mount and you want a proper tripod it
does not have to break the bank or just
get maybe already have one you get a
smartphone Mount you do want to make
sure that it goes vertical because of
course you're doing shorts and Longs but
if you got something like this Amazon
Basics fifteen dollars the one other
thing to consider is that how tall are
you and so a mistake people make is they
just go oh the tripod looks good and you
have no idea actually you know you're
like I'm sure it goes tall enough and
then you realize 50 inches is uh that
would be like shooting at my chest and
so I need like 70 to 75 or 80 which you
could put this on a countertop but some
immediate Investments because most of us
could probably swing you know
25 40 bucks for a tripod and then a
decent smartphone Mount that ends up
getting shot composition great using our
smartphone and one other thing I would
recommend is uh you've got a wireless
mic this is one of our favorite ones
we're going on budget hacks today this
one right here
has
um
there's a lightning Port version and a
USBC version and we're at 27 is a two
dollar coupon on it you can see we've
purchased this two times this guy is
kind of cool you're actually literally
the advertisement's a cook kind of food
example with a phone on the left side of
the screen you can see it right that
phone tripod uh and the the mount there
and then clip it onto your shirt clearly
that was
get a stock photo and then just
Photoshop the little thing there City
there it's too funny but uh we can vouch
for this Omar El takori on the team
loves this mic and there is one for uh
iPhone IOS and then there is a USBC
version of this as well and so for
definitely under a hundred dollars you
may even go softbox lighting and that
could take your current camera and make
it pop a lot more but you know for 25
here tripod maybe 25 that's 50 or 60
bucks you could probably get a softbox
lighting kit you can for under 50 and
boom a hundred dollars and it's gonna
change everything a hundred dollars
you're gonna take your smartphone video
production and take it to a whole nother
level and so a couple tips there hit
like if you've been getting value and
we're going to get into some of your
questions that have been coming in and
uh in just a bit we're going to be going
through a title training so definitely
make sure to watch until the end today
uh but let's start off here with how can
I use shorts with my book review type
video so it takes time for me to listen
to the audiobook Dan
so I think if you're doing book reviews
and you want to do shorts I would love
to see it like this you probably have a
long form video planned right it takes
you time to listen as you said but you
can probably get a good feeling about
the book and what your thoughts are on
it before you finish it right so if you
already start to form that opinion you
want to get a short out what I would do
is take if it's an audiobook take your
phone hold it up to the camera and as
part of the short right and you're like
this is the best book that you can
listen to right now for blank whatever
the book is about whatever the value of
that book is think about the audience
what this what is this book going to do
for them that's what a review is all
about so I think you could do a very
quick synopsis of this book in just a
few seconds and then say stay tuned I'm
going to be doing a full review uh up on
you know coming up soon so that's that's
almost the call to action the subtle
call to action to subscribe after
watching because now you have like a
longer review to look forward to
really good Sophia what is the best time
in the U.S when it comes to finance to
upload shorts so the niche is finance
best time of day to upload shorts Dan
any opinions on this
whatever time works best for your
schedule honestly I mean you're gonna
post shorts and YouTube is going to kind
of sit on those for a bit I'm sure
you've seen this where they do nothing
nothing and then suddenly everything
suddenly you get all the views all at
once and then they do nothing again for
a bit so any time that works best for
you I would say I like to post mine in
the morning us you know time zones uh
but I've posted I've had some that I
feel like this is a little bit more time
sensitive I kind of want it out now six
o'clock at night posted online nothing
happens for the first couple hours then
it kind of blows up a little bit it and
then it continues to kind of ebb and
flow depending on the short and how well
it's doing so I think time to post yes
for your regular viewers whenever
they're on is great but ultimately what
works best for like your schedule that's
it's not gonna hurt I don't think yeah
and you can always use schedule upload
the workflow of that is kind of janky at
times if you're Mobile versus desktop
and we've been talking about that at
think media but you know just doing your
best and so we'll do a lot of schedule
upload on videos
um we also don't hesitate to post even a
couple shorts a day so people say I
think I would have here's our advice you
do want to avoid like any magic numbers
number one even if there is some magic
number
it probably will only be true for a
couple weeks or a month so you can't you
don't want to build a whole strategy
around it it's just kind of a constant
testing and experimenting so we've been
learning that sometimes experimenting
with uploading in the afternoon uh Dave
Bay who's uh I'm doing some coaching
with and one on on a one-on-one level
was saying that he would upload a short
in the morning he would get 18 views and
stop so he deleted it uploaded in the
afternoon and we get two thousand two
hundred so that's an interesting thing
but I want to warn you like
that might work for you for a while too
but that in and of itself is is just
maybe a way the algorithm is working
right now but it may not work in the
future one other thought is that
ultimately
and this comes from YouTube's mouth
themselves when time of upload doesn't
matter because
if we're doing YouTube properly and of
course we teach this a VRA when you
upload we have videos 10 years that were
posted 10 years ago that still get views
today
so does it matter what time that video
was uploaded it's still getting views we
have shorts that were posted two years
ago that are still getting views today
so does the time of day matter what when
it gets uploaded so rather than even
thinking about like oh time of day in a
boost of views if you're getting people
are not swiping away the topic is Broad
enough or at least broad enough in a
niche an average view duration average
percentage viewed is 80 plus 90 plus
well then really the short is much more
about how many views it's going to get
over the next 30 days 60 days or even
Beyond rather than the day of course
maybe some early momentum could lead you
to those metrics sooner or cause it but
even one of our videos that Nolan molt
did that is at 8.5 million views took 30
days before it even actually really
started to get views and so again the
YouTube algorithm
is going to be researching uh or rather
studying and analyzing a video
and as it quote unquote finds an
audience or finds viewers that it's
satisfying in measuring the average
percentage viewed and all that kind of
stuff then ultimately over time that
video can perform pretty well and this
short is that 8.5 million views right
now it had two runs of straight up
virality and then it kind of plateaued
and now it's just slow and steady but it
actually is still getting views to this
day so rather than thinking about the
time of upload think about the quality
of the upload because if you do it well
then ultimately it's going to
uh keep performing well well beyond the
first 24 hours Buffet bass fishing
channel I imagine ask I have a question
would you recommend nishing down instead
of doing phishing content on my channel
should I Target more specific audience
so that says only bass fisherman in
order to grow faster Dan
I I wish I knew more about fishing but I
do feel like just knowing that there are
such a thing there's such a thing as
bass fishing boats for example can you
catch other fish with them you know the
answer that I don't but it does sound
like bass fishing itself excuse me is a
whole culture so in this case yeah I
would test it uh and there's no harm if
you have some ideas it sounds like you
might do it for like a month and if you
don't like the results or if you miss
doing other other videos you were doing
there's no harm in pivoting back to what
you're doing before because I still feel
like
niching out eventually to other types of
fishing is like the logical step here
but if you feel like oh there's like a
whole community of bass Fishers I could
really Target with my content then hey
that's great like that could be a really
really great place to start you can
always Niche out later
um I I wish I knew more about fishing
because I I would have a more definitive
answer but uh yeah my very limited
knowledge tells me there's no harm in
testing
you know a couple of things that I think
are interesting here too it feels to me
like you already are niched to Bass as
in the fact that it's in the title
um I don't think that would be hurting
you I think that fishing is a clear
enough niche in my personal opinion I
also like it's kind of just a unique
thing I've never seen before but I love
that you have Channel values here listen
to these Channel values think media
podcasts create Community Live
passionately stay positive love others
and yourself be yourself spread joy
laughter inspiration and motivation help
others stay healthy love life and live
life to the fullest and do what you love
uh also disclaimer for affiliate links
which is cool and so I think that that's
just kind of a cool way of I mean were
just at this moment is my first time
seeing your channel and connecting with
you and already that build such a deeper
Bridge of connection by you saying your
channel values very simple not a lot of
people probably even make it to the
about page but that was pretty cool
um
we a lot of times recommend having a
everyone says Niche down I think you
should have a focus but I think your
channel can be too niched but at times
your videos can't necessarily be too
niched because there's not a lot of risk
in experimenting with a video a certain
type of video or let's call it a series
a 10 or 20 or 30 videos can ultimately
um they'd be on brand nobody would be
offended if you're talking about fishing
or talking about things but they might
be like that's not my style so some of
your subscribers may not click on it but
it very well could lead to a lot of
opportunity so I would I would think a
little bit differently rather than like
should I change the niche of my Channel
or Niche my channel more I think what
it's about is experimenting with
specific videos or specific topics that
are focused to phishing in general but
it actually might open up a new
opportunity where maybe if things got so
crazy in doing a test that's maybe the
summary of the tip don't be afraid to
experiment don't be afraid to experiment
with a video or five to ten videos or a
series the worst that could happen is
you're like that didn't go very well so
that's not the direction I'm going but
if you don't experiment you may never
basically do the r d the research and
development that could help you evolve
and innovate your channel and so it's a
great question but I think your
opportunity is to uh you got so much
great stuff Happening Here congrats on
almost 5 subscribers congrats on you
know building out some monetization with
affiliate links and having some merch
um and it looks like you're pumping out
some great content and so I think as you
continue to make small tweaks
um this is going to continue to go
really well and let's go to the next
question and hit like if you're getting
value uh we do Christian based online
marriage counseling specifically for
marriages that are recovering from
infidelity is that too niche
yes
I think I mean I think that uh that it
is Niche enough to do christian-based
online marriage coaching or to do just
like because back to this so ties into
the last question
that could be a whole series that might
be one of your most popular series
videos on that topic might be uh some of
the most profound and impactful videos
but you don't have to make the channel
That Niche right simply those who from a
Christian perspective want to work on
their marriage or heal their marriage or
strengthen their marriage and so
we teach understanding your audience's
problems and Ambitions so it's not just
the problems of infidelity or not just
the problems of that that's a big you
know challenge to help someone through
but also think about the whole we'd call
it viewer Journey
what about also the things past that
five love languages taking things to
another level the dynamic of having a
kid two kids so I think you can play
with so many topics inside of the vision
and saying that
it's because you won and resurrecting
hope is a really good channel name it's
because you want to have
you don't want to be too niched so that
you don't
limit your ability to grow in a five to
ten year window if we want to build a
legacy and build a brand
and we're too Niche today in our Channel
even name is too niched where is this
thing go five years from now but imagine
meeting somebody where you're like
literally resurrecting hope I I searched
because we had infidelity in our
marriage I met them on the channel but
now it's 10 years later
and it wasn't just that but I was able
to eventually go to their marriage
Retreat I learned about how to not just
get my marriage out of a very negative
thing but to get into ever increasing
levels of positivity and growing and New
Dimensions of understanding and
respecting each other and encouraging
each other and strengthening our
marriage and the seasons of life and so
yes I would say
that uh
that your channel could have lots of
inroads into your world with the
different topics but in the meantime you
still may do your next 100 videos all on
recovering from infidelity just knowing
that you could pivot beyond that or or
build beyond that over time next
question is don't a lot of people cut
a lot of their long videos into two to
three shorts Dan thoughts on chopping
down your long videos I think a lot of
people do that and I think there are
people who do it really well and people
who make one very very crucial mistake
and that is context when you take a long
form piece of content and you forget
about the people who were not there to
watch the long form video you end up
giving somebody something that doesn't
make any sense to them right you put
this in shorts they've never seen your
content before and there's an
expectation that well they'll watch the
long form video this will make sense
when they watch the long form video so I
would just urge you to do that but be
very careful and one thing I've seen
that works really well is take the clip
that you want as you're short and if if
you're lacking the context in the
original edit give yourself an
opportunity to sit down do a quick vo
for the shorts viewer like I was playing
this game and this crazy thing happened
you'll never believe it then let the
clip roll as it was
so just provide that context for
somebody who has never seen you before
because shorts is all about reaching a
new audience a whole new audience of
people exist on YouTube now who just
like watching mobile vertical content
that's really really short and bingeable
so
you know cater to them
really strong
um if you're getting value hit like
we're going to do another Channel review
in just a second and we have a title
training coming up but I want to welcome
you to the think media podcast Channel
subscribe if you're not subscribed let
me know how long have you been a part of
this community how long you've been
following think media the podcast
podcast about two years old we do extra
live streams like this on the channel
but I'm super excited for this next
question I think this is going to help
you make more money and so architectural
sheet metal 101 says what type of review
video converts the best into affiliate
sales the answer is the versus video let
me illustrate so we do if you go to the
think media channel you go to the search
the channel feature and you just type in
vs versus you're going to see that we do
this all the time full frame versus crop
sensor what is the best light for
lighting YouTube videos under um 200 and
we have the godox sl60w versus the gvm
80 watt you've also got best streaming
microphone sure versus deity versus
Samson and the reason this is the best
strategy for converting affiliate sales
is when somebody is searching for the
comparison of two products they are the
closest to the moment of actually making
a purchase because they've narrowed it
down they're like okay am I going to get
the Sony zv1 or the Canon M50 and then
based on your review adding value
letting them know the pros and cons of
each they very well could make their
decision on that video and then
educating them about your affiliate
Links at that point in time
to illustrate this
um in just every Niche this would be
relevant to
um here's a I've been looking at pemf
mats pulse Electric magnetic field
inflared blankets the red light masks
have you seen my wife Sony has one of
these they wear little Darth Vader masks
like the people in the thumbnails here
it's scary every night I'm terrified as
you can see from these uh super scary
masks but
um you could take a brand like higher
dose so someone's like I want to buy a
pemf mat Tire dose versus and they're
like I've narrowed it down to the higher
dose versus the my high so imagine you
have done your research you're trying to
pick up a sauna blanket and you're down
to this particular video I think what's
fascinating here is this Creator only
has 646 subscribers but there's 871
views on this video proving to us it's
search viability because someone's
looking for something very specific
which of these two products should I go
after uh interestingly enough too
um lazia should actually be a VRA member
because she's missing out on money like
she doesn't even have her affiliate
links I guess she says non-affiliated
opinion which is great which I think you
should share your unbiased opinion or
your you know transparent opinion but
you should also have the links because
you can say listen do you want this one
or that one link to both in the
description down below and so if I'm at
this moment where I'm trying to talk to
somebody and again our goal here and do
an affiliate marketing is ethically
serving people recommending products we
know love and use and have tested
ourselves or have researched ourselves
that we would willingly recommend to
friends and family my friend Rick called
me the other day because I've been
researching pemf mats I probably put 30
hours into it so he's like I don't want
to take 30 hours Sean can you give me a
three minute explanation of all the
research you've done and so just like I
would tell Rick my honest answer I'm
like bro I'd probably get these ones up
based on all my research this is the one
I'd go after and so in summary
the type of video that converts best
into affiliate sales is a comparison
video because the person is at the point
of purchase and again you're just
telling them the fully transparent
uh Truth where this gets bad is if
you're recommending the one that has a
better affiliate Commission well then
that's you're kind of sacrificing your
integrity because you just should be you
shouldn't you might even recommend at
times I saw a guy that I bought red
light panels from uh who recommended 10
and hit one of his some of them did not
have affiliate programs so I want to
encourage you to our ethic here in the
think media world is like we want to
tell you what the best product is
hopefully there's an affiliate program
but if we're like yeah and actually this
one doesn't even have one but like truly
this is the best remember that over the
long haul you building your brand you
building trust you're building a legacy
matters most because there's going to be
plenty of opportunities where again
probably both of these products have an
affiliate and you're like listen this is
what I'd go with because I like the
features better made I felt better you
know links in the description down below
let me know if you have any questions in
the comments
um and so the versus strategy is the way
to go when it comes to that today's
video is brought to you by vid IQ by the
way that's our affiliate link and our
sponsor for the video uh but you can get
a 30-day trial and vidiq's paid plan for
just one dollar at iq.com forward slash
think this is one of those products
that we know love and use and I've been
using for
since the beginning I mean I want to say
I've been I downloaded that iq's free
extension vid IQ vision and got a free
account
10 years ago and ever since then they've
continued to add new features and this
is a tool that we regularly reference
for making better data-driven decisions
but what's really cool is now there's
some cool AI features they have an
interface and an AI YouTube coach
that'll help you improve these different
details in terms of your YouTube channel
so if you haven't grabbed a one dollar
trial for 30 days of one of their paid
plans that's how you can unlock some of
these features and I asked Dan to do um
to show us how we could write better
YouTube titles using this and so uh Dan
uh take us into some cool things that we
could do to ultimately make better
videos get more clicks get more views
and uh break it down
titles are just so so important and
we're at a time now where I think a lot
of people still kind of hold on to this
really old advice where you know your
titles need to be really really
searchable but these days like emotion
really wins The Click through your title
and your thumbnail I've always said
these two things should work together
but
um we we are treating them separate
right now because we are going to be
looking at the AI title recommendation
tool that's just one of the things now
what's cool about this is you can use it
in two different ways your channels are
probably niched into some kind of area
right some kind of industry so knowing
that you can use this to find video
ideas because when it generates titles
it's going to come up with things you
probably weren't thinking of and you can
use it to help understand how to make a
title that you're thinking of make it a
little more interesting so I have an
example pulled up on screen right now it
says how to scuba dive uh we saw a scuba
diving Channel earlier so I decided to
plop that in there and this is going to
give us a few different things so when
you hit get title ideas it's going to
take a second to think about it and then
you can keep hitting get recommendations
if none of these are jumping out to you
but it's going this direction unveiling
the secrets to becoming a scuba diving
Pro unlock the secret to successful
scuba diving unbelievable tips to help
you master scuba diving unbelievable
tips to successful scuba diving your
first time will blow your mind I think
this is a bit long but okay interesting
unlock the secrets of scuba diving just
uh you know it's really on this unlock
unveil unbelievable it's designed to at
least remind you if you don't like any
of these words change them out but at
least remind you that hey like put some
emotion behind this what yeah it's scuba
scuba diving tips but what's the value
of them well you probably haven't heard
these before these are are literally
unbelievable so and you can just keep
generating new ideas and trying to hone
this in but like sometimes unbelievable
discover how to scuba dive without
breaking the rules
this is kind of an interesting thought
like I might not use this title verbatim
but now I'm thinking about what are the
the rules I could break while scuba
diving so like things not to do
scuba diving
if I could spell
so now I'm starting to brainstorm videos
diving disaster don't do these things
underwater what a fantastic title and
and I can even start to imagine a
thumbnail where you have an angry fish
you know uh and and you're you're just
you know you're in your scuba mask and
you're shocked or you're trying to swim
away like you know don't don't do these
things you know like maybe it's you
trying to poke something with a stick
there's there's so many different things
coming to my imagination so this is a
great tool for not only getting a really
solid title but brainstorming and
getting your mind into a different place
because when you go on YouTube right now
and you look at the top titles on your
home feed
are you going to see a video as boring
as how to scuba dive or are you going to
see something a bit more emotional I
haven't even looked at this today so
this probably shouldn't pull this up as
an example but
um here's here's one example from Colin
smear is YouTube about to get worse and
the CEO I quit
is YouTube about to get worse how
searchable is that I'd say like three
out of ten but this is an emotional
title they posted this a few hours ago
there is a couple thousand views on one
of their newer channels too so that
that's what they're doing here they are
targeting an emotion they know their
audience very well it's people who who
take a lot of time and spend a lot of
time getting YouTube news and YouTube
stories so everyone knows the CEO of
YouTube is moving on and now they're
like what's gonna happen and they're
they're poking that that's you know the
Poke and the bear with the drama there
so that's the point I'm trying to get
across
that's a powerful tip on emotion and uh
triggering emotion thinking about how
you can make your titles more emotional
and again that's just one of the many
tools and so if you want to uh try that
all out click the link in the
description or check it out at vidiq.com
forward slash think for a uh 30-day
trial of vid iq's paid plan for just one
dollar our next channel is loving Tech
life and I'm super pumped that I have
Dan here because there is a leaning
towards gaming in this case it's gaming
Tech and let's look at a few things here
um it looks like we've been uploading
just for the last eight months even
though the channel was created a little
while ago so that's cool we are at a
place of 68 000 views some breakout
viewership it's always so cool we say go
for green and we have 1295 growth
2176 growth in subscribers with only six
uploads so I probably uh maybe some of
those could have been a YouTube short
we've had a couple four thousand view
YouTube shorts happening and then over
here on videos
um we've got wow four days ago 28 000
views 24 000 views and 81. so we had it
these really popped off so it looks like
um and then we have one of my favorite
features on vid IQ once you get vid IQ
Vision installed it's vph BPH stands for
views per hour and so we have an 11 day
old video that's getting 17 views per
hour this is the dream and we always
talk about this in video record Academy
you want to get views 24 7 365 on your
older videos here's one that's a month
old that's getting 30 views per hour so
Dan what are your thoughts on this
channel
so just as you were scrolling I'm
noticing like this new VR video you did
completely blew up PS2 VR is is a thing
I think it was announced recently
um I'm a No Man's Sky fan I'm noticing
the thumbnail in the background of that
thumbnail was no man's sky and they just
released an update like yesterday that
was for the PS2 VR like there's gonna be
ps2vr support like oh so like you're
gonna this is a really good time for you
because there's new equipment coming out
and there's new games and game updates
coming out uh what I will say with this
channel is that they haven't quite
picked a niche yet even if they feel
like they have in my opinion because we
go from VR and then we go from
connecting a controller to your phone
and I can see how those feel like
they're in the same realm it is gaming
it is gear but VR channels are their own
thing on YouTube and they are a very
thriving vibrant space that is actually
continuing to grow because VR headsets
are becoming more accessible to the
average consumer so
I think with this recent success you've
had it's time to come up with a strategy
and see if you can double down on this
content right here on on covering being
either the person that covers everything
there's no PS2 VR or VR headsets in
general comparing PS2 VR to the next
Oculus device that comes out or if uh
steam updates their headset or HTC or
whatever it might be
um you know just try to put yourself in
this VR space if you can because as you
can see there is an opportunity here one
channel I like to follow in the space is
called thrill seeker they've been at it
for a while they test a lot of new and
upcoming VR gear they're reviewing a lot
of things channels like this are more
Tech channels than they are gaming
channels but they do have a gaming
focused audience
um you are going to be giving your
viewers a lot of value if you go out and
review products VR products are
expensive there's haptic suits and
gloves and all these things that but you
get your hands on some of that stuff you
start giving reviews and versus videos
and things like that like you're gonna
be you know really really helping the
people who are in the space who want to
spend a little bit of their disposable
income on this very expensive version of
gaming but want to do so logically
because there's this technology moving
very quickly and there's a lot of
different products out there so I think
you can make a whole Channel around this
one video one or two videos for you that
have just completely popped off and I
hope that's your plan here
and that's some brilliant advice from
Dan just to emphasize a point for
from what he said and for all of us
watching when we experience this moment
and I think you're at this moment he
mentioned you've recently hit kind of a
bright spot you've hit some momentum and
now double down and even adjust your
focus related to that I would just
encourage you great job great job with
the hustle over the last eight months
working on your video production working
on all those details now you have a
couple breakout videos really lean in
and uh Dan and I look at channels all
the time you know we've been doing this
for so long there's almost a feeling you
get and you when you kind of like you're
like oh there's it's time to it's time
to hustle and so I would you know
there's Sprints we do I think for a
sustainable Pace we don't want to burn
out we don't want to uh you know we want
to be they're burnout so common for
Content creators but there's sometimes
when it's time to really lean in and I
would just challenge you like you got
some really cool stuff happening here
based on applying Dan's advice and just
thinking about how can I really ride
this I think you could experience some
explosive growth as you double down it's
time to double down let's look at a
couple questions here and
um
we've got
if you are using all the right hashtags
and thumbnails any other ways to get
views I do better with shorts versus
long videos Dan
because of the opportunity of the shorts
right now I'm not surprised to hear that
especially if you're a newer Creator and
like shorts are quicker to make right
they're much much shorter so even a
really complex short doesn't take as
long to edit as a long form video so
they're faster to put out there and
shorts are distributed on YouTube a
different way the long form videos so uh
when you're saying you're using hashtag
using thumbnails you're looking for
other ways to get views I'm glad you're
doing shorts because that would be my
first suggestion is to continue doing
shorts and treat that audience like you
would any other viewer because these are
views that you might not have otherwise
gotten with long form videos as I said
earlier I believe there's an audience of
people out there that don't watch long
form as much as they watch shorts so
it's great that you have them in your
community and you're catering to them
uh Lori s kind of just dovetailing right
off that prior question in your opinion
Dan if you're starting a brand new
channel would you start with shorts or
longs I would certainly brainstorm away
I could do both
um like with my personal Channel I'm in
a position right now where I'd rather
just do shorts because it's faster I
have a lot of stuff going on
um I like both because I like to create
a Content ecosystem I want my my channel
to utilize live streams Community posts
long form videos short form videos
um I would say for you to start with
whatever makes the most sense for you uh
how much free time do you have to be
making YouTube videos in the first place
uh what are what are your ultimate goals
does the content you make feel like it
would fit with like shorts or are you
really struggling like this is you know
this video essay content does not fit
into the short form space and maybe
that's okay so there's there's a few
things to think about without knowing
what kind of Channel you're you're going
for I don't want to like say
definitively one way or another
yeah and uh I would say Lori and I know
we have a lot of uh folks from our video
ranking Community here
um I would I would recommend that a lot
of new creators start with shorts for
the reason that Dan mentioned because
they are easier to create you know
creativity can work best within
constraints and we recently here's
here's a reason to do short form content
a couple reasons is one they are simple
and easy to create too they do get a lot
of views right now three you get
exposure new audience four YouTube is
promoting them and five it's still early
shorts are two years old but they're
just adding monetization right now
there's some new analytics adding inside
of the YouTube studio and so there's a
lot of benefits to shorts but another
reason is that depending on your
business model and your goal shorts
could be the tip of the iceberg when
you're creating vertical video you
essentially have assets that could also
be posted across multiple different
platforms we have a lot lot of
entrepreneurs and people that want more
leads clients and sales in our world and
so a huge opportunity is just creating
vertical video in general being
thoughtful about learning best practices
of platforms but then realizing you can
distribute them across multiple
different platforms and one of the case
studies we share is Anton is a real
estate agent who just using a Samsung
S21 and cap cut as his video editor was
able to start posting some shorts even
though he hadn't uploaded on his YouTube
channel in 10 years and he got 16 000
views in the last 28 days 20 new Subs he
did 28 uploads he basically uploads a
vertical video a day and he really
doesn't know what he's doing so it's
like sometimes you ought to just start
messy done is better than perfect just
you know punch fear in the face and
press record but because he's also
uploading these vertical videos daily
around real estate investing in real
estate he's also been able to not just
pull 2 000 views 7000 and Views his
strategy is one vertical video a day but
he's using these same assets also across
multiple platforms now if your business
model is more entertainment or it's more
like YouTube is the focus there may not
be an Roi for you posting over on
Facebook reels and other places but
again he's been able to find as a busy
professional and maybe you're in school
and maybe you have a lot in your plate
right now a job or two he's able to
sustain this and with one vertical video
it takes him less than 30 minutes to
just you know distribute that across
platforms and if you see here this is
the same video Facebook reels got 5400
views Tick Tock got 481 Instagram reels
got 469 and then YouTube shorts got 1
500. again
he just started messy with YouTube
shorts and vertical video and he's
figuring out as he goes and so uh Lori
um you I'm not sure if you're part of
our video record Academy but we just
added our YouTube shorts Deep dive
training it's three hours
um and it kind of as you can see it
Blends into these other platforms which
could seem like a distraction like wait
is it about YouTube or is it about other
platforms but I heard Mr B say recently
too he said the reason to do a video
podcast is like not even the podcast
it's the fact that the vertical Clips in
a 2023 world will get a hundred times
more reach and Views than even the
original piece of content if you
understand this strategy and so I
definitely recommend uh watching that
that's again a part of our our bigger
Academy but Dan what is your thought on
this vertical Video Revolution
um that is kind of happening and are you
a proponent of multi-platform is that
part of your thing are you fully focused
on YouTube I I'm more focused on YouTube
uh but I I have been experimenting with
taking my shorts the ones that I feel
like work on all the other platforms
right they just feel General enough and
putting them on the other platforms and
I've been pleasantly surprised by
getting you know let's say I have a
YouTube short with 50 000 views getting
a hundred thousand Tick Tock or
sometimes the opposite sometimes it
tanks on Tick Tock it does great on
YouTube sometimes Instagram reels just
completely pop off so I I am a proponent
of that if that's something you want to
spend your time doing personally I don't
like spending extra time uploading Here
There and Everywhere like it's a it's a
thing I have to keep up with because
YouTube has a nice scheduler these other
tools don't so having to sit down and
take the extra time to remember to
schedule the content when I have so many
other things I'm juggling that does slow
me down but if you can do it I am a
supporter of that for sure and I think
that shorts right now I can tell you
like has made me a better Creator it's
gotten me to be even more concise and
tell a really nice clean story as
quickly as I can it's made me appreciate
the attention span of the viewer today
and I use those same strategies now my
long form videos how can I we talk about
much earlier in today's show how can we
like get right into the content and if
you start making shorts and they start
to take off and you experiment with
those things you're going to start to
notice wow when I get right into the
content my shorts people watch the whole
way through sometimes twice I need to
try this for my long form videos I need
people to click on the video off of some
perceived value and they need to
understand I'm going to get that value
when the video starts right away so no
splash screen for 20 seconds explaining
who you are all that stuff goes out the
window it's you clicked on a video about
blank it is indeed about blank
uh amazing one uh final Channel and then
a question or two after this hit like if
you've been getting value today a lot of
nuggets and if you're just joining us
live let me know where you're watching
from and uh and check out the replay
because we dropped a lot of different
nuggets and if you're watching on the
replay drop hashtag replay fam in the
comments this channel is called brick
built and it's a team of Brothers Isaac
and John who've been building original
Lego models and have been active in the
afol community for over 10 years the
channel
they show Creations Creations along with
tutorials build blogs photography
presentation tips
and a lot more to help you with
designing and presenting your own builds
and so we're seeing Lego builds here
and we have finally as Dan drops some
wisdom on US 46 uploads we're seeing a
lot of gopher green channels right now a
lot of growth and and that's and just to
encourage you again I always want you to
celebrate there's so much comparison
that can happen where sometimes we can
have a negative Viewpoint like oh my
channel is not growing I actually hear
this a lot Dan someone will literally
say my channel is not growing and then
I'll be like besides it's growing 278
percent besides it's growing because we
just like if it didn't go viral like Mr
Beast then I'm not growing it's like no
celebrate the growth because if you keep
compounding this the opportunity is
pretty massive and so I would imagine
let's see the builds two days six days
nine days thirty four weeks one month
maybe seven uploads or six uploads in
the last 28 days so out of the 46 that's
a lot of shorts and so that's cool
genius use of Lego stud Shooters Lego
ice Planet micro Outpost design we're
pretty neat because we're talking about
just one thing with a zoomed in shot and
um and so Dan what are some of your
thoughts I I love it I think they're
doing some fantastic work here uh it
just something about that video reminded
me when you said one thing that did
remind me shorts right now are
searchable shorts are showing up as
results in Search and so I don't like I
don't know about this channel if they
can try to like test out some shorts
that are more searchable maybe maybe
build something out of a popular TV show
or movie or something like that but I I
really love that they are going with
that strategy of like my short is just
about one really really quick thing
these tiny little builds add so much
detail to an oh to a larger build so if
I'm a Lego fan and I'm scrolling through
and this comes up it's like oh that's
cool like I can make that in a few
seconds and I have this like big bass
that I'm building I could put those all
over the place you know so there's ah
man I really feel like they understand
their audience they understand like how
to set up a good shot I'm getting
exactly what I need from this no more no
less
I think one of the things that I love
what she said is if you could do what
we've branded is called Trend surfing
and especially because you're doing
custom builds what I actually think
would be amazing because you've dialed
in production that's for sure so your
production the the wood table the look
The the depth of field the shot looks
beautiful looks great your lighting
looks good so if you could do a short
that started off with the final result
first you see a Harry Potter character
or you see something from Avengers or
the most recent Ant-Man or something and
you grab that attention right up front
and then you reverse engineer the build
and especially the more maybe but I I
suppose if it was quite literally
something that
is just showing off an actual Lego
um branded build but if it's also custom
just this culture would be like whoa and
they're going to want to watch that like
okay so you made an original Lord of the
Rings looking and my guess Dan is the
viral potential of that is insane right
short at the right time based on the
right trending movie trending show
trending viral Reddit
uh you know comic
um a book or or something that's
happening and release other Niche
YouTube channels subcultures
um because you're you're then tying it
into Lord of the Rings meets Lego and uh
that could be a great opportunity for
you and I wanted to see
Let's see we haven't up we've been
pretty consistent here for a lot of
years and so
um that's awesome what do you think
about these thumbnails I love them I I
think uh some some I like more than
others especially like the blue
background with the the one little
simple build there but even the ones
that are zoomed out it's kind of hard to
tell what they are I wouldn't
necessarily say we should change
anything because scale is also
impressive you know all that missing
detail for me right now on that build
you just clicked on I kind of might want
to click the video just to see like the
more intricate parts of it so uh I would
say those thumbnails aren't jumping out
to me as much but still strategy is
there I think they're doing a really
really solid job this is cool too
um I think what's interesting to me here
is that this video is only 30 seconds
what's your opinion on that this
yeah so this is just like a quick
use
showing up final build just practically
there was a time where I was posting
videos under a minute that were not
YouTube shorts and they were doing
exceptionally well and then I learned
that
first came out YouTube admitted like oh
we kind of broke YouTube with that
because YouTube suddenly realized hey
people really like short videos whether
it was a vertical video or not it was
promoting shorts and then they said we
fixed that and so I'm like huh maybe
that's why my 32nd my sub 30 second you
know long-form videos aren't doing super
well anymore so now I'm telling people
if they're making 30 second videos you
should probably just make it a short but
that all that being said I've still seen
some videos under a minute perform well
um you know I just think that the market
for long-form Content it's it's people
who are sitting down to maybe turn
something on and they're maybe not in
the mood to browse a lot imagine someone
watching TV uh and eating dinner and
they want to watch YouTube they click on
your video because it looks cool and
they realize 30 seconds later they got
to get their remote their hands are
dirty because they're eating buffalo
wings now they got to find the remote
and they're like a buffalo wing sauce
all over the remote does this sound like
something that I've been through I I'll
never tell but I'm just saying sometimes
you like a longer video because you
don't have to get Buffalo sauce all over
your remote
oh no
I went to the community Tab and I see
this sentence this channel hasn't posted
yet why
man you know what is uh something to
consider is that the the community tab
now is available to channels of all
sizes you go into your back end and you
simply apply and check a few boxes it's
kind of like verifying at another level
that you're legit to YouTube if you're a
new channel
um if you're at 10 subscribers it you
may not get a lot of benefit from the
community tab but I would argue at 866
subscribers that is also an opportunity
of of doing some polls getting some
feedback asking some questions putting
some Square images there again as you
think about Community tab
yes you can also promote some old videos
to new subscribers and things like that
but a lot of it's quite literally the
name of the tap it's just about beauty
building community so we just posted
four hours ago a question that's it just
one question very short
um we a lot of times will post or the
format for the photography and the
design is square that's a big key to
know and so we will post just valuable
based stuff on its own or here's a
square version of one of our recent
videos
that um is the is the best way to
promote a video put a nice photo or
design and then Link in the first two
lines or first line of text to the
YouTube video and so good tip and good
reminder for all of us watching right
now
use your community Tab and I want to
challenge you if you're watching this
video and you haven't used it go over
there and do a poll or do a question do
that in the next five minutes like do it
as you're watching this very video just
to kind of condition yourself you know
you could be posting on the community
tab literally daily I would hope weekly
and especially if you're closer to a
thousand or Beyond don't ignore your
community tab it can actually lead to
new subscribers but one of the big
things is it can lead to depth of course
if you have new people meeting you this
month but you've been in the game for
years it also is thinking about some of
your hits from the past that you may
want to promote there and those could be
a few signals that also get some clicks
get some watch time it might even kind
of boost a little bit those videos being
recommended because you're just kind of
cross-promoting content within your own
channel and so do not ignore the
community Tab and the final thing I'll
say too as we do a couple final
questions is I really believe everything
you've learned everything all the skills
you've been building thumbnail design
video creation your expertise in the
custom designs I really sense some big
opportunity coming for you on the other
side of making a few small tweaks I want
to speak to the Grind you've been
posting for years and you're not at a
thousand subscribers right now and I
don't know how you're feeling but
sometimes it can be maybe feel a little
discouraged or why am I not bigger
there's this is a good Niche it Ebbs and
flows and especially as you tap into
Trend surfing and tying this into of
course rings of power you know a ring of
power is out and so Lord of the Rings
hits kind of a a Revival in terms of
awareness tapping into the MCU of course
you got to be on brand for what you're
passionate about but there's no doubt
about it my friend Caleb said YouTube's
Trends in Psychology that was like hit
somebody goes really YouTube comes down
to Trends in Psychology if there's like
two big things understanding what's
trending that doesn't mean
abandoning your Niche or your focus it
just means what what's trending that's
related to my Niche and that could tie
into it and then psychology the Creator
who understands the viewer best wins so
what what are people thinking about what
people want to see and what are people
who are not subscribed you've been
serving this community of 866 people but
there's a hundred thousand people and
beyond that haven't discovered you yet
how do they think what are they into
what would they click on what would they
find fascinating the Creator who
understands the viewer best wins
um all right Laurie asks can you have
affiliate links with shorts in the
description section
the answer is yes but it's very
difficult to get to the description on a
short
you might as well because why not
you know even optimizing shorts do tags
really matter on shorts that much not
really I still do them I use vid IQ and
I quickly click the the vid IQ logo so I
can add the appropriate tags I still do
a short description because if YouTube
gives me the field I want to do best
practices I'm most concerned with the
title and I will put affiliate links in
the description but here's your big
opportunity Lori pinned comment
the pin comment of a short is something
that you should be really thoughtful of
I will use the pin comment on a short to
link to another video
I typically that's my favorite but if an
affiliate link is relevant I will put
the affiliate link there and I'll put an
asterisk and make sure to disclose that
it is an affiliate link so that would be
your better opportunity and we in our
shorts Master Class recently we we
revealed uh we looked at a channel that
was a van Life channel and even in there
short they listed like four cool
accessories they couldn't live without
and number three was like these packable
blankets and they said
text on screen there was actually no
talking in the short text on screen said
check out the pinned comment for our 20
off coupon code
as you're listening to the music and
they're using visuals to show off these
accessories for Van life and so pin
comment is your big opportunity when it
comes to that
um Gina's asking what's the best
strategy to change niches Dan
well uh it kind of depends so if you're
going to Pivot really hard away from
what you're doing with your current
audience you have to consider a couple
things uh is there any chance at all
that at least a fraction of them will
like the next thing you're going to do
and maybe based on the fact that they
know you they might but maybe there's
like a slight Venn diagram there if
there is then I say okay cool same
channel et cetera et cetera but I had a
situation where I was pivoting away from
a content in a really big way and what I
decided to start a whole new channel
because the channel is pivoting away
from was still making passive income and
what I didn't want to do was disturb the
videos that were doing so well by trying
to bring in a new audience and confuse
the whole thing it made more sense to
let that channel be on its own thing and
I could always come back to it in the
future and then start fresh with
everything I learned from that first
channel on the new channel and it worked
out very well for me I'm very happy I do
it that way so that would be kind of my
advice to you is to really look Inward
and say is what I'm about to do
different enough to constitute a whole
new channel Channel I don't know Sean if
that's the conventional advice but
that's my own experience tells me that
would be the first question
oh I love it that's some fantastic
advice Dan as we land the plane today uh
tell us a little bit about what y'all
are doing over at vid IQ
uh we like Sean here we want to help
creators we want to help you uh meet
whatever goal that is whether you just
want YouTube to be this fun hobby where
people follow you because they just are
on you know the same Journey you are in
terms of your hobbies the things you're
doing or if you want to become a
full-blown business owner with your
YouTube content that is what we aim to
do we want vid IQ to be a place all
creators can learn about all things
YouTube
yeah I love it so if you haven't uh
subscribed to the vid IQ Channel you
definitely want to subscribe over there
there's also Channel reviews that happen
weekly a show that they do and some
video reviews uh Dan also really
specializes in gaming so they kind of
separate out the gaming versus
non-gaming channels and so a lot of cool
stuff happening over there can we show
some love and hit the like button for
Dan adding so much value today Dan we
appreciate you thanks so much for coming
on thank you thanks everybody
and uh think media podcast Channel
um definitely check out you can see
Victoria on team think
um we have today's video brought to you
by vid IQ you can get the paid plan for
just one dollar at vid iq.com forward
slash think a lot of cool tools and
features are happening inside of there
and then um I want to remind you uh if
you're not subscribed subscribe to the
think media podcast Channel
um the vision of this particular Channel
and the core is a weekly show at least
of one to two episodes
of our think media podcast and most
recently we sat down with Nolan and Omar
and myself and we have some new content
new episodes let me know have you seen
this episode yet this is a new format
for us we were able to go to the video
Department which is a project that Omar
launched here in Vegas that pretty cool
set huh what do you think about the set
and um we've been shot a whole batch of
podcasts and so if you like Spotify or
Apple
uh or any of anywhere you listen to
audio podcasts you can get that version
but it's also a video podcast that you
can of course subscribe on this channel
too
um and uh watch on a weekly basis one to
two episodes uploaded every single week
the think media podcast Matt saw the
episode Pierre loves the new format
Shelly I appreciate the feedback on it
yeah we're excited and so we're trying
to innovate and we'd love your feedback
uh about
um topics you'd love to see in fact you
know the chat here is sometimes hard to
study but if you have any topic ideas
that you'd love for us or questions that
we didn't answer today
post those here on the replay of
um this video so that we can we'll
research those and we would love
to build some episodes excuse me off of
some of your ideas in regards to um the
think media podcast in your ears
and potentially in front of your eyes if
you watch it here on YouTube every
single week my name is Sean Cannell
rhymes with YouTube channel thanks for
being a part of this live stream today
and I will see you in a future